los datos de tres puntos en una función
suave que están dados en la siguiente
tabla y nos dan valores de x contra sus
valores que tiene en la función entonces
cuando x es 1.49 que es 4.176 y bueno
creo que será mejor irlos graficando
para que sea mucho más claro qué es lo
que está sucediendo y otra vez voy a
pintar un poco más más derechitos los
ejes
creo que se funciona bien
dejes muy bien este es el eje x este es
el eje que corresponde a efe x muy bien
y aquí voy a hacer unos cortos digamos
voy a dejar unos huequitos indicando que
en realidad estoy dejando un buen
espacio verdad para que quepa todo aquí
muy bien entonces ahí estamos dejando un
espacio amplio y aquí vamos a poner a
1.49
más cerquita 1.49 1 punto 51.51 ahí lo
tenemos y por acá arriba tenemos 4
puntos 17-6 4.16 84 puntos y 4.15 4
entonces vamos a poner aquí
4.15 por aquí el 4.16 y por aquí 4.17
muy bien ahí tenemos esos tres puntos y
entonces vamos a graficar primero este
en 1.49 vale cuatro puntos 17-6
aquí vale 4.17 y más o menos hasta acá
arriba muy bien ahora acá abajo vamos a
ponerlo con rosa digamos en 1.50 vale 4
punto 16 8
aquí vale más o menos
por aquí
muy bien y finalmente lo ponemos en rojo
1.51 vale 4.154
más o menos por aquí ok entonces no
sabemos exactamente cómo sea la gráfica
voy a hacer digamos un intento de quizás
cómo se vería
más o menos aquí
quizás hace algo así más o menos ahí
está la gráfica entonces ya que tenemos
esto graficado nos dice cuál es la razón
de cambio el cual es la razón de cambio
promedio de g con respecto a x a medida
que x varía desde 1.49 a 1.50 luego de
1.50 1.51 que corresponde a este
intervalo y luego del intervalo grande
de 1.49 a 1.51 entonces vámonos vamos
haciéndolo por partes y nos tomamos
primero este intervalo en 1.49 y 1.50 ok
entonces vamos viendo cuáles son los
cambios en x y los cambios en ye
entonces el cambio en x el cambio en x
vamos de 1.49 a 1.50 entonces tenemos
que la diferencia es de 0.01 muy bien y
ahora en ye vamos d
cuatro puntos bueno más bien sería ir de
4.168 a 4.176 o bien de 4.176 a 4.168
pero va hacia abajo entonces va a ser
negativo entonces el cambio en yes menos
menos algo y en realidad son 0.008 0.008
muy bien entonces vamos a calcular la
razón de cambio promedio esto
simplemente se calcula como el cambio
entre el cambio en x pero nuestro cambio
le dijimos que era menos 0.008 y aquí
dividido entre 0.01
entonces esto esto cuanto este esto es
algo negativo y podemos multiplicar por
mil arriba y abajo eso nos queda acá
arriba como 8 y si multiplicamos por
1000 acá nos queda 10 y 8 entre 10 no es
otra cosa más que 0.8 entonces si te das
cuenta de esto de estos dos puntos estoy
encontrando la razón de cambio promedio
y esa razón de cambio promedio no es
otra cosa más que la pendiente de la
recta secante verdad como ya vimos en
vídeos anteriores y esa pendiente
aquí vale menos 0.8 entonces esta de
aquí es menos 0.8 muy bien vamos a ver
cuánto vale en este intervalo ahora nos
fijamos entre unos 51 51
fijamos aquí
este cap y este cambio otra vez el
cambio sólo desde en x es de 0.01
mientras que nuestro cambio en cuanto
vale pues ahora vamos de 4.168 a 4.154
pero para abajo verdad vamos para abajo
entonces va a ser algo negativo y en
realidad son 0.3 son 0.0 14 verdad
0 14 muy
entonces volvemos a hacer esta cuenta
vamos a hacer el cambio en que entre el
cambio en x esto fue menos 0 puntos 0 14
entre 0.0 1 muy bien y entonces digamos
podemos multiplicar por 100 arriba y
abajo y esto simplemente nos queda menos
1.4
- 1.4 y aquí lo ponemos menos 1.4
vámonos finalmente a que nos piden en la
razón de cambio promedio de 1.49 a 1.51
déjenme hacerlo ahora por acá arriba
este cambio bien entonces nuestro cambio
en xy nos damos cuenta que aquí es un
0.01 y otro 0.01 entonces estos son 0.02
y ahora el cambio y pues vamos hacia
abajo verdad vamos de aquí hacia abajo
entonces va algo negativo y es de 4.176
4.154 y esos son 0 puntos 0 22 muy bien
entonces aquí nuestro cambio en entre el
cambio en x es igual a menos 0 puntos 0
22 entre 0.0 2 muy bien entonces
efectuamos estas operaciones esto es
algo negativo podemos multiplicar por
100 y nos quedan 2 puntos 2 entre 2
multiplicamos por 100 arriba y abajo
verdad entonces me queda 2.2 entre 2 y
eso no es otra cosa más que menos 1
así que aquí tenemos menos 1.1 y ya
tenemos resuelto toda esta parte vamos a
la siguiente pregunta nos dicen
utilizando la razón de cambio promedio
de g en el intervalo 1.49 1 puntos y
1.50 y 16 estamos hablando de este
intervalo grande que representamos con
morado y eso como una aproximación para
la pendiente de la línea tangente a efe
en x igual a 1.50 ok entonces la recta
tangente aquí quizás sea más o menos
algo así y la pendiente la vamos a
aproximar por la pendiente de aquí muy
bien entonces escribe una ecuación para
la línea tangente en g en este punto de
aquí que es 1.50 4.168 usando la forma
punto pendiente muy bien entonces
recordemos que la pendiente sobre la
digamos sobre esta línea la pendiente es
constante y de hecho esa constante la
puedo calcular como ye
el punto por donde pasa que es 4.168
sobre x menos
x menos 1.50 verdad
1.50 y eso debe ser nuestra pendiente
sin embargo la pendiente la estamos
aproximando x menos 1.1 así que esto
queda como menos 1.1 muy bien y entonces
lo único que tenemos que hacer para
determinar para la ecuación de la recta
tangente dado bueno habla aproximada es
simplemente pasar esto multiplicando y
nos queda que ye menos 4.168 es igual a
menos 1.1 que multiplica a x menos 1.50
y esta esta ecuación de la recta en su
forma punto pendiente